what's the believe nation welcome to
another YouTube live I'm pumped to be
here we're doing an AMA answering your
questions so I'm happy to be here it's
been a it's been a it's been a
ridiculous ridiculously amazing week
just really pouring a lot into growth
into into making things better there's
so many crazy projects that I'm working
on right now and they're all they're all
pushing forward which is amazing but I'm
taking a break from everything for the
next half hour to be here with you guys
I want to make sure I'm answering your
questions and providing value I was
talking this morning a lot about failure
and I think so many people are wrapped
up in failure so many people you tie
yourself worth to the failure you know
we're not afraid of failing we're afraid
of feeling in front of other people and
I want to change the conversation where
I want you to think about tying yourself
worth to not the result but to the
effort because the results alone if you
or if you want to race against the
three-year-old you're not going to feel
great about yourself because it was an
easy race it's not just about winning
it's about doing the work it's about
when something is hard and you do it you
feel great about yourself regardless of
the outcome of if that ends up yielding
a big result for you or not yes it's
great to win but if you can tie your
self-respect not to the winning or
losing but tie your self-respect to the
effort that you're putting in to respect
yourself for putting in extra effort
when it was hard you showed up not just
when it's easy you show up because
anybody can show up when it's easy but
when it's hard when everybody else would
let you off the hook and say don't worry
about it
sleep in forget about that thing right
when everybody else is complaining you
show up and do the work if you tie your
self-respect your self-worth to that
you'll be unstoppable and you may not
win every time you go out the gate
nobody does but if you keep doing that
you will eventually win or so many
people are so afraid of failing the
first time that they never start yours
so afraid to fail that you don't even
try unfortunately that's most people and
I want to I want to break that because
you're tying yourself war if you respect
to the win loss instead of the effort
and hustle behind it that's my little
rent for the morning or I guess is not
morning anymore it's 12:30 here on the
East Coast I want to get to your
questions give me questions let's go
welcome everybody I love seeing people
come in on the live chat it's amazing
it's amazing if you guys tag me the
questions a lot easier for me to see it
so just do the act I become a little
pop-up Lang logic hey Evan welcome Lang
Jeff you were featured on my website
today
I appreciate it Jeff Jeff Cunningham go
check out his website I'm on it I love
it
what else Evan Bravo hello Jerome what
are your favorite personalities so first
off I love learning from somebody who's
had success I love learning from
different people from different walks of
life if you look at the channel we
featured at the beginning only
entrepreneurs what we branched out to
have musicians and actors and
politicians and people from all walks of
life because I love hearing the
different perspective and the different
takes I particularly love trying to
learn from people that I don't like
somebody who if I just watched their
content sometimes they might annoy me
they might stand for something that I
absolutely don't agree with and I love
the challenge of finding something from
that person that they can teach me to
help me become better because it's easy
to just get locked into the mode of I'm
only gonna learn from this kind of
person I'm not gonna learn these things
from this kind of person and I think
that's really limiting I think I think
that actually hurts you as a human being
I think when you can learn to learn from
people that you hate is when you
actually grow so those personalities
like some of my favorites are on the
wall behind me but if there's somebody
who who I disagree with a lot of what
they stand for and I can find a way to
learn from them that's what really gets
me excited right you tie your
self-respect to the effort it's easy to
learn from somebody who's super
inspiring and motivational right that's
easy but to learn from someone that you
hate that's the challenge that's what I
love doing alright nice we got we got
hashtag or we got tagged me and
questions I love it so much easier to
see thank you guys next sugar pop Evan
how do you deal with the toxic ex but
you have children involved thank you so
much we'll get into parenting advice
with EXO me being divorced one of the
things that I was really really focused
on so my ex-wife
Hayden is with my ex-wife terms of like
who's the the mother and one of the
things I really really focused on was I
want what's in the best interest of my
son always and I'll put my ego to the
backseat to make that happen
so anytime there's a discussion I try to
make it about Hayden and what we need to
do to make it the best situation for him
I think anytime you start attacking any
time you say well you're always like
this and you never do this I think you
lose you've lost you've already lost any
time you start attacking somebody you
have lost and if they are attacking you
I try to find the aspect of it around
around the Hayden I try to find the
aspect of her around your child and
that's always a primary focus it doesn't
mean that you need to be massively
disrespected or yelled at but how you
choose to react to it is important right
if you respond by yelling back and
hurling more insults you lose the whole
thing you lose and so thinking about the
child first I think is super super
important good that's my question
Lange logic Evan how do you live in the
present after overcoming a failure one I
I try to think that the failure is here
to teach me something I expect to fail
going into most things I expect nobody
to show up I expect the first time
through for it not to work anytime I
launch something brand new I just
expected to fail because most things
fail at the beginning and then I don't
attach my self-respect to the to the win
or the loss did I work hard to try to
make it happen did I put my best into
making that video or launching that
course oh right in that book making this
t-shirt like that I put my best into it
am i proud of the effort and if I'm
proud of the effort then I
know that if I keep putting in effort
whether it's in this thing or the next
thing eventually things will work out
and that's been not just my story but
the story of every successful person
keep putting in the effort eventually it
will eventually will work and you'll
fail a lot along the way but I tie how I
congratulate myself how I feel about
myself - did I put my best effort in as
opposed to did this thing work or not
next boots off how do I sell a product
in the market which has a saturated
industry and stiff pricing competition
there's always room for quality always
if your stuff is good there's always
room for quality I get this ass a lot
with people I want to start a YouTube
channel how do I win on YouTube is so
competitive there's so many people if
you're good you will gain an audience
follow what I'm doing on Instagram
YouTube
I have 1.5 million subscribers almost
Instagram
I've got like 17,000 now a couple months
ago I had a lot less Instagram is
saturated Instagram is mature I am
starting Elementary I'm not even
promoting much like I'm not using my
YouTube channel to promote the Instagram
channel I'm not really using my existing
networks to promote it I like this might
be a twisted crazy thing about me I'd
like winning inside the platform I want
to win on Instagram because of how good
content I can create on Instagram I
don't want the hand up I don't want the
leverage from something else I want to
win in that platform I want to go into I
almost want to go into it as like nobody
knows boy if it wasn't a personal face
if that wasn't part of like what I did I
want to go in as a stranger I want to go
in with a with a pen name I want to have
a I want to be a ghost ghost written
just for the challenge of winning where
nobody know there's no brand affiliation
or history built-in I like that
challenge so watch run don't Instagram a
lot of people say that that is too
saturated some ature I'm posting six
times a day I'm posting pictures I'm
posting videos a lot of it is still me
I'm manually posting a lot of the
content myself when I first said I did
everything myself now we made some
systems a little better my team is
helping I
go live four times a week on Instagram
I'm putting in the work and each time we
do it we get a little bit better I just
posted a new form out of the picture
that is that is 5x saying my other
pictures it's awesome and I just
discovered that and I'm gonna keep
tweaking and making it better and
improving if you think that you're not
gonna win in an industry because the
saturated you've lost like you're right
there's always room for quality in every
industry
always and forever and so can you
provide quality if you can't then you've
lost but if you can then you will always
win in any industry
I actually prefer to get into a mature
industry and provide better quality than
to be the first one of the first next
thing is I'm not the first I wasn't the
first to get on YouTube and take it
seriously I'm not the first to get on
Instagram I am late to Instagram I don't
like being the first I like going
somewhere that is already established
and then providing better quality and so
you can do it too always room for call
at the top so Lima how do you meet
like-minded people in person when is
your cafe opening Wow Salima is lame as
a hardcore fan so for a couple months I
was talking about building and
entrepreneur cafe I really wanted to
build an entrepreneur cafe was it was my
next business the idea that local
entrepreneurs have a place to go to
where they can meet other entrepreneurs
be around like-minded people have drinks
named after people entrepreneurs have
like videos playing whether it's a top
10 or some other videos on the screen
have resources you know like business
plans to look through and just have a
place to work and to connect with other
entrepreneurs and I didn't I didn't do
it because I ended up investing into
Lily's business Lilly is in the live
chats and Lilly this is all your fault
and I don't know if I'm gonna do it
again like I I'm still like the idea I I
wish somebody else would do it just like
I wish somebody else would make the top
10 or wrote the one word book like I
wish she just had a somewhere to go but
if nobody else creates it I may end up
at one point creating it in terms of how
to find like-minded people I think it
first starts with just the intention
that you wanted
do it because you may not be getting it
in your in your life right now you may
not begin some people around you one you
can look to offline communities look at
meetups look at the vents look at any
things that are happening in your area
maybe travel if you can afford to to go
to different events I look at the
workshop we did in May and how how tight
everybody became as a result of spending
the three days together in that intimate
environment whether you can afford to do
that or not four different events I look
at online communities to I think post in
and believe nation is a lot of people
who even a believe they are connected to
each other and they've never met face to
face but there's somebody that now has
become their friend because they are
comment on each other's videos and
connecting with each other off through
email and through other social media
networks just you around like-minded
people and so it starts with the
intention of doing it I would look to
both offline and online communities and
not not settle not give up not lose hope
it was really important to you I came up
with a new mantra for my in special
videos that I recorded yesterday he
hasn't come out yet but it's called flex
the ex flex TX so one of the things I
have here is a is a yearly calendar
right so whenever I have a goal that
that is is it's a habit whenever gold
let is a habit change and I have a hard
time doing it it's not normal for me to
do it like for me to get up and make
make an Instagram video it's just part
of my mood routine I don't need to
reward myself for that because it's it's
just easy I don't need to remind myself
but if there's something that you want
to do that is a habit that you would
need to remind yourself I encourage you
to get a year-long calendar and put the
X now I haven't I got a mark off my
August yesterday I landed not just
yesterday I did it and so flex the X
like if you want to connect with people
then then print off your yearly calendar
and put an X every day that you have
made an effort to connect with somebody
again we're not attaching our
self-esteem and our self-respect to
actually making a great connection it's
to the effort and so every day we're
flexing the X we're marking on our
calendar that we did something today if
you did that right like if you did this
for the next three months right every
single day if you did that you will make
great connections you may not make a
connection today you may not make a
connection on Sunday like not every day
is gonna work but if you did that every
day consistently for the next hundred
days you flex the X you will make great
connections and so just making that a
priority making that a habit goal every
single day - whether it's an offline
event that you're gonna go to and meet
up with people whether it's a seminar
that you're gonna go travel to and
connect with people or whether it's
through different online communities
like a live chat like this or comment in
somebody else's video or respond to
somebody's Instagram DM or tweet you
know you're making an effort every
single day flex the X and make it happen
like it's good we got we're getting some
flex is happening in the inner chat I
love it lang logic what is your biggest
piece of advice in terms of branding
branding is around that emotion brand
news around core values my biggest piece
of advice is figure out what your core
value is so the process that I use is
your one word my one word is believe
this is my brand it's just it's not just
the word though it's the feeling I want
people to feel like they believe in
themselves and their talent and what
they can accomplish through everything
that I make through a live chat like
this the videos that I create by reading
the book when they put on a t-shirt I
want them to feel the power of belief
that's through everything and so it's
clear it's easy to understand it's
that's the the road not just for people
to understand you but for you to create
projects that are exciting for yourself
so you've got a podcast what am I gonna
get from your podcast what is what is
the feeling that you want people to get
every single time you listen to a
podcast figure what out what that is and
it's not just a branding for the for the
company it's it's you like Zac Lang
being around Zac Lang you will feel this
what is your one word and then bring
that to everything that you touch
including podcast website Instagram
YouTube t-shirts books everything that
you do thumbs up appreciate the love
block success great and consistent job
thanks I want my company to move to the
next level we are 6 digits financially
but it's hard to afford to hire
preteen to help to get us that next
level advice if you can't afford to hire
the person full-time then hire them
part-time if you can't afford to get
that person five days a week into your
office then hire somebody as a
contractor remote one day a week just
like however you got your way to the
100k right if it was all you find but
now we start bringing on people
part-time people that's how you started
like I would much rather have the person
who can make a big impact but come in
once a week and do that thing then to
have somebody who sucks five days a week
I just got off the call just before this
like I was almost late for this because
I was talking to another youtuber who's
building up his audiences got almost
half a million subscribers on this
channel and we met I mean we're looking
at doing more collaborations and I was
giving him a lot of feedback was telling
them about the length of the videos and
the frequency and the thumbnails and the
title and the types of videos he was
putting out and how to how to squeeze
more juice out of each video that he's
doing I want him to triple his
subscriber growth over the next year
right helping him do that that time
spent with me in half an hour
was super worth it right now I didn't
charge him for the time we're looking at
ways to collaborate but having somebody
come in he couldn't you know he couldn't
afford to have me come in and work in
his business full-time and I would want
to even be in that situation right be it
wouldn't be what I want to do and be too
expensive for him anyway but having me
come in and look at it and give feedback
and give him advice for him and his team
to then follow up on is how you start
bringing in world-class talent so
instead of thinking full-time you might
get there you might get to hiring that
person full-time but start thinking
part-time lilies in the chat you know
you couldn't afford to have Lily come
and work full-time in your business but
you could do a weekly coaching session
with her and it'll help right so that
kind of thinking where's a world-class
talent that I need and how can I hire
them for one day a month or one day a
week to help them get me where I need to
go next
anooshka how do we work as hard
how do we work hard as worst as we could
how can we do hard work as worst as we
could how can we do hard work as worse
as we could I don't really understand
that question how can we do hard work if
that's the question I would say one you
have to be doing you have to be doing
work that is meaningful everybody who's
had success who like the number one
thing is they love what they do net
right like you may not love every single
moment of every day in your life but
like they like the work there's
something above making money the process
of making the thing like if you want to
do why do I do this I love it this video
actually hurts my channel like net this
video will have lower views than my
other videos on the channel it'll it'll
lead to unsubscribes every time I go
live I lose some subscribers on my
channel I do it cuz I love it I love it
like I'm not doing really important
projects right now to be here with you
guys in half an hour because I love it
right you have to love the process don't
try to make youtube videos if you hate
making videos if you don't want to have
a message right go do something else
it's how you will win but when I'm when
I'm doing work that I love it's it's not
hard to get up and do the work right so
you have to enjoy the process of the
work that you are doing if you want to
continue to work hard because you can
force yourself to do something you can
but you can only force yourself to do
something for so long like you will
eventually quit if you absolutely hate
doing this work you will quit and you
will ask yourself how do I stay
motivated well you don't have goals that
excite you and you're not doing work
that is meaningful to you so fix that
it'll help next hard work goes progress
I like it
hard work and talent have to be balanced
sure I mean you're giving you have
whatever gift you have that's your gift
you can always work hard that's like
your ticketing is always hard work you
can beat people who have more natural
talent than you by working hard next
akaash i mean i living in a negative
environment in school depressed kills
mainly stuck
if you
mentally stuck can't focus on chase
parent dreams please help one you know
that that sucks I feel for you two I
would say you need to shift the mindset
that the thing that's happening right
now to you is awesome your purpose comes
from your pain somebody asks for an
Instagram can I go and do something
amazing if I have no if I have no pain
in my life and I've never been to
anything major like I don't know I think
it's hard the people who I see winning
they went through something I think it's
really hard to have the purpose-driven
life without having suffered you want to
ease the suffering for other people this
is your suffering this is great like out
of this you will become amazing the
strong trees grow because they had
adversity strong people grow because
they have adversity so stop thinking
this sucks and my life sucks
Salima give me a super shot 279 thank
you for the love this coffee is on you
Celina I appreciate it instead of
thinking this sucks
I think this is helping me grow this is
helping me grow this is the best thing
for me out of this I'm going to be a
monster I'm gonna be insanely strong
because of this negative environment
you're throwing at me and then three I
would say start changing some of your
habits and your routines whatever it is
it gets you feeling optimistic and
positive put that into a regular routine
for you
so I like to think of it as I consume so
much believe every day
I am body belief but I take it in my
morning routine is about believe the
videos that I watch is about believe
like everything I'm taking in so much
sunlight every day so much believe
sunlight that if you sneeze on me with
your negativity I'm not gonna catch a
cold
and so that's what I'd want for you
you're taking so much positivity so much
optimism so much whatever your one word
is like you've designed what you can
control in your life around that what is
your first 30 minutes your day look like
what are you listening to or what are
you watching on the way to school right
what books you're reading what video
watching part time when you come back
bring so much of that into your life
that when somebody sneezes tries to
infect you with their negativity it
bounces off like you know I'm not
getting sick you're not gonna make me
not believe but if I was weaker if I
wasn't consuming as much if you catch me
on a bad day and I didn't practice
feeling myself up every day then you
might drag me down into your negative
camp but I'm so strong and when I
believe not because I'm an amazing
person but because I do the work because
I design my day so that I inject myself
with so much of it every day you're not
gonna bring your neck I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna the whoever is more
confident is gonna win I'm gonna make
you doubt your negativity if you were
hanging around me and you're the most
toxic negative person in the world I'm
gonna turf crack in your wall I'm gonna
start making you doubt the negativity
the lack of belief just because you're
around me because my wall is so strong
if your wall is strong I'm gonna chip
away you're not chipping away at mine
I'm gonna chip away at yours right in
this area just like if I was around
people who were working out all the time
I'm sure that I would want to work out
more if I was around people who were
eating salad all the time and eating
super healthy I would probably eat
healthier I would do a good job but like
I could do a better job I'm not as
strong on that but believe optimism
positivity I am the strongest you will
not break down my wall I will break down
yours right and so having that mindset
that mentality I think can really help
you all right what do we got
RCA I'm trying to be a music producer
but I lack skill money tech support time
and almost everything but I had this
huge dream to be a good inspiring music
producer one day stop focusing on what
you don't have
stop it you don't have you will never
have enough stop focusing on what you do
not have instead start asking yourself
what you can do with what you do have if
you are good this is all you need skill
you acquire by practice by beating on
your craft
by doing the work that's how you get the
skill everything else you just need to
be resourceful you have everything you
need the people who came before you
people who are hitting it hard in your
industry they started with lesson what
you already have right now they'll stop
focusing on what you do not have and ask
yourself what can I do with what I have
right now that's it that's always the
answer for anybody out there it's like I
can't start youtube because I don't have
a camera I can't I can't start this
because of blank as long as you believe
that story you will lose because there
are people who have done it with far
less than what you currently have right
now they just didn't believe the excuse
so stop it stop telling yourself what
you don't have you will lose forever and
always just be resourceful we got a
couple minutes left you guys got me all
fired up today by the way there's a new
setup I think you notice the microphones
not my face anymore it's a little
awkward cuz I got a look off screen to
look at my comments but anyway hopefully
I'm coming in loud and clear Block E
media bin from Vancouver area I do
interviews with this version people
wonder if you'd be interested and the
best I'm used to make it happen email
Sandra act Evan Carmichael calm and
we'll make that happen next we got we
got four minutes left what do we got
Evan what advice would you give for an
aspiring musician that wants to make an
impact as a big artist just make content
man make songs I'd make a song a day a
song every day I would not worry about
the editing I would not worried about
any of the gear people aren't gonna want
to listen to you because of the
fantastic editing that you've done look
you want to get discovered this is guy
conditioned my screen anyway look up
look up Rockabye Lawrence Park Rockabye
Lawrence Park I've had this song on
repeat for like the past month this song
has six million views this guy's 365
subscribers he's still smallish like
he's getting there
if you produce more content man you
would win so hard you stop producing
enough but the editing is
nothing just him blocking my videos very
little editing you just not making
enough a song a day I want to see you do
cover songs I want to see you do you
know duets like this one Rockabye he has
an Marie she's singing her part he's
singing his part they use it app called
Smule and then every now and then you
release your own original well you don't
need to come up with your own original
song every day do covers like take me
through take your style on a Backstreet
Boy song your style on an Eminem song
like do a little something different on
stuff that's currently out there but
every single day releasing a song using
this just set it up and start singing or
start doing the guitar or start playing
piano whatever it is and if you can
afford a microphone awesome 100 bucks if
you can't don't do it yet don't worry
about it don't let the gear hold you up
it's the same answer to that last
question don't focus on what you don't
have would you love to have a fancy
recording studio 100% would you love to
have an entire team and people helping
you for sure even now I look at what I'm
doing I could use 20 more people to help
me build my brain I could do that I'm
welcoming it I would be happy to have
these people on board and if I want to
do something I will be an army of one
and I will will it into existence you
need to have that mindset you're always
looking for help you're not shutting
help you want support you want people
that give you assistance and I bet if
you asked you can probably find people
who would be willing to volunteer to
help you out but if you don't get it
instead of sitting at home and
complaining about what you don't have
you will be an army of one and will it
into existence a song every single day
cover song summer rituals of yours I
want to see it up on YouTube guys it's
one o'clock time flies and you having
fun thank you for the love I'll see you
again next week
there's still time left own today to
make it count like before you hit your
head on the pillow I want you to do
something you look back on today and
said I'm gonna reward my effort my
effort was spot-on today you may not get
the results you may not get the
you mean I get the sales you mean I get
that song out but your effort was
spot-on and you could be proud of
yourself you're gonna pat yourself on
the back hit your head on the pill and
say man I'm proud of how much I worked
on my goal today do that
thank you guys I believe in you over
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where is much love
I'll see you soon